I have a great documentary
recommendation for you today a few
viewers recommended it it is a 2014
documentary called poverty Inc and it
basically looks at the global fight
against poverty but from the standpoint
of critiquing some of these social
entrepreneurship organizations and some
of the NGOs and other groups that are
huge huge beneficiaries of all sorts of
government and enterprise money and it
does actually kind of look at the issue
from a Christian theology angle the idea
of Christian charity and I don't mention
that as a critique it it's it's
incredibly well done you'll just notice
that some of the philanthropists and
people working in countries afflicted
with significant poverty uh often come
to those jobs are those vocations
through a Christian perspective which is
perfectly fine but what really is
fascinating about this film Louis is it
points out that a lot of these
initiatives that seem great like for
example there's that shoe company toms
which says for every pair of shoes we
sell we will donate a pair in South
America or wherever it is that they do
it and the critique is that doesn't
solve poverty because that's a plan that
depends on people not being able to
afford shoes for themselves and the fact
that indefinitely people in those
countries will need free shoes it is not
actually helping local business develop
and that in the film makes the argument
actually that by giving away free shoes
when you feel like it in these countries
you're actually disrupting the demand
for the locally produced shoes and maybe
even hurting local businesses so it is a
very different approach at the elements
of charity and social entrepreneurship
of course it it takes a perspective and
people should watch it and then evaluate
and do research but a very interesting
film that does sound uh quite
interesting I haven't seen this one yet
it is on my list and over the years
we've covered countless stories of of
just corrupt charities yet and things of
that nature and it's uh it's ugly out
there yeah this is poverty inc and it's
listed along with all of my other
documentary and book and film
recommendations at david pakman.com
slash recommendations warby parker is
offering a free five day home try-on to
give
the opportunity to check out their
glasses i personally wear warby parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try-on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trial dot-com / TDPS I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses well the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home try-on I was
able to pick five pairs that i liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker calm /
TDPS it costs nothing